bonjour à tous et à l'inattendu au pas
de course que nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui nous sommes ici à vincennes
le temple du trot français l'occasion de
remonter le temps des grandes courses
hippiques de revoir quelques-uns des
chevaux star les fameux krach est de
retrouver une figure bien connue des
turfistes pierrette brès
[Musique]
là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent à tricoter
d'accord là-dessus à votre place je la
ramène un peu moins mais si vous ne
réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous manque
qu'une seule chose un tout petit détail
le trophée des valises à paris de ce qui
lui arrive à la bulle
l'inattendu est aujourd'hui à
l'hippodrome de vincennes le temple du
trot français avec pierrette brès
bonjour pialat brésil bonjour vous avez
longtemps accompagné conseiller les
turfistes dans leur pari comment
s'inscrit cet hippodrome vincennes dans
l'histoire hippique française ouais il
est mythique et ben s'aiment bien sûr
c'était l'un des premiers l'hippodrome
construit en région parisienne et en
fait ce sont des éleveurs de chevaux de
trait à la campagne en normandie
principalement qui petit à petit se sont
pris au jeu en faisant des courses de
clocher en clocher avec laurent blanc
bourrin comme on disait parce que
c'étaient des chevaux de trait ils se
sont dit on va essayer de faire de une
race un peu plus rapide finalement donc
ils ont fait des mélanges de sang et
voilà comment maintenant on se retrouve
vincennes avec des chevaux de haut
niveau parce que vincennes c'est quand
même le temps du trotteur en france et
même pour les étrangers parce que le
jour du prix d'amérique par exemple vous
avez les chevaux du monde entier les
meilleurs shows du monde entier qui se
retrouvent ici il ya une petite émotion
qu'on retrouve cette piste les cavaliers
les bruits aussi il vous reconnaissent
aux ben oui mais c'est normal 40 ans de
métier sur cet hippodrome il ya de quoi
vous reconnaitre pierre est ce que je
vous propose c'est de retrouver camille
d'auxerre et ludivine lopez les
journalistes de la rédaction nina pour
parler des femmes dans le milieu
hippique des parieurs des chevaux et des
propriétaires et de vous bien sûr eh ben
ça me va
[Musique]
cette salle de l'hippodrome de vincennes
nous offre un point de vue idéal sur
cette piste mythique qui accueillera
dans quelques jours le prix d'amérique
regardez paris qui se dessine à
l'horizon nous sommes avec pierrette
brès notre invité de l'inattendu et
camille d'auxerre jeune journaliste à la
rédaction dinars dont jean camille les
courses hippiques sont irrémédiablement
associé aux joueurs aux parieurs ici on
dit des turfistes oui miser de l'argent
sur une course de chevaux c'est une
passion française depuis les années 50
mais exactement nathanaël le turf comme
on l'appelle a piqué les français dans
les années 50 et pour beaucoup c'est
bien plus qu'une petite distraction du
dimanche j'ai un chiffre à vous donner
pour vous donner un petit peu eu une
idée de l'ampleur du phénomène en france
il y a dix sept mille bureaux de poste
et bien dans le même temps il ya plus de
13 mille endroits où on peut jouer au
pmu c'est presque un service public dans
notre pays pmu pari mutuel urbain pour
faire simple c'est l'entreprise qui a le
monopole sur les courses hippiques dans
le pays et donc les courses ont piqué
les français dans les années 50 c'est
surtout le jeu du tiercé qui a
popularisé toutes ses courses hippiques
depuis donc plus de 70 ans dans les
années 40 les hippodromes sont des
endroits réservés à une certaine classe
sociale ou on aime se montrer les
courses ont repris ce premier gros
dimanche de l'année est un pas texte
pour les élégantes d'arborer les
nouvelles toilettes printanière mais en
1954 c'est la naissance du tiercé un jeu
simple peu onéreux fait pour attirer les
foules mais les débuts sont un peu
mollasson tout change en 1956 quand le
jeu débarque à la télévision
les courses hippiques se popularise les
français deviennent tout simplement
acres au début on avait que les
fanatiques maintenant tout le monde
s'est habitué à jouer sans son numéro de
voiture soit son acte de naissance soit
son numéro de téléphone au numéro
quelques mois je me demande toujours ce
que ce que l'on faisait quand tu n'irais
pas le cas c'est le dimanche et bien ça
c'est une bonne question car le tir
c'est rapidement devenu la nouvelle
religion du pays la messe laïque du
dimanche en quelque sorte est-ce que
vous jouez aux tirs ses
démarches c'est donc bien ce qu'on
appelle un phénomène de société faites
vos jeux marquez vos chevaux messieurs
dames pour le tiercé de ce dimanche à la
fin des années soixante cinq millions de
français jouent au tiercé moyenne de
mise cette france et même les pouvoirs
publics s'y intéresse tous les rapports
secrets qui circulent dans les
ministères disent bien que le tiercé
n'est plus un jeu une simple distraction
c'est une névrose nationale une
obsession dominicale à l'échelle de tout
un pays une névrose nationale pour
l'assouvir les bars pmu où l'on vient
jouer poussent comme des champignons il
y en a en tout quatre 1812 en france
alors imaginez l'aubaine que représente
pour les patrons de ces café pmu
l'invention du tiercé qui le ramène le
dimanche matin parfois plusieurs
centaines de clients pendant des années
les courses vont donc faire battre le
coeur des français mais dans les années
90 le tiercé perd un peu de sa superbe
la progression du loto des jeux de
grattage donne du vague à l'âme aux
paris hippiques avec le pmu on joue
comme on aime dit le slogan les français
eux jugent surtout comme une âme et ces
derniers temps ils ont plutôt tendance à
bouder le tiercé qui ne représentent
plus que 15% des enjeux deux fois moins
qu'il ya cinq ans mais les parieurs
fidèles sont toujours là quitte à y
laisser quelques plumes
je trouve que vous l'avez estimer à
combien vous avez perdu au moins
lorsqu'on me avant il y avait trois
tiers c'est dans la semaine maintenant
il y en a tous les jours tout était
pourtant joué plus vite à ce système qui
veut ça pour attirer une nouvelle
génération de joueurs les courses
hippiques ne se regardent plus à
l'hippodrome non plus au bar pmu mais
sur internet où les sites de paris se
multiplient à faire ses jeux sur
internet c'est
peut-être aussi beaucoup plus calme on
peut plus réfléchir plus peut-être
sentir ce qu'on fait que si on est sur
un hippodrome avec
depuis l'âge d'or des courses hippiques
dans les années 60 et ses 5 millions
d'adeptes fidèles nous sommes passés à
environ trois millions cinq cent mille
français qui de temps en temps continue
de miser sur le bon cheval mais que ce
soit à l'hippodrome au bar pmu ou devant
son ordinateur puis une seule règle
demeure pour faire un bon joueur voiture
touchant ce lot grâce et la littérature
pierrette brès vous avez connu l'âge
d'or des courses hippiques aujourd'hui
donc trois millions cinq cent mille
français continuent à jouer mais le
coeur de cible c'est vraiment cinq cent
mille personnes comment vous expliquer
cette perte de vitesse des courses
hippiques
je dirais que ça pas été une bonne idée
finalement de mettre des courses
hippiques à la télévision parce que ça
vidé les hippodromes et les gens ne
venaient plus directement à l'hippodrome
il ya aussi une chose qui est assez
étonnante avec les courses hippiques
c'est que de prime abord quand on s'y
connaît pas on peut penser que les
hippodromes sont réservées quand même à
une certaine classe sociale aux gens
plus privilégié quand on est extérieur à
tout ça en tout cas mais pourtant c'est
un sport ultra populaire alors vous
parlez de sport de privilégier en ce qui
concerne les propriétaires oui je pense
mais ce qu'on appelle la pelouse là bas
au milieu oui c'est justement réservé au
peuple qui n'a pas beaucoup de sous pour
venir s'installer aux balances ici on
appelle ça les balances voilà merci à
vous en tout cas camille pour pour ces
informations sur sur les turfistes comme
on dit la passion du turf on va parler
de ses chevaux de ces cracks que vous
avez bien connu mais d'abord on va
regarder quelques images de nos
champions
il lui faudra montrer qu'il est plus
qu'un simple cheval mais un athlète un
champion de la marne tout proche monde
ces brouillards léger que l'aurore
soulève mais au rythme du trot yvan
s'évanouir et ce cheval qui vient c'est
le meilleur que connaissent vincennes
c'est une jument en fait c'est masina la
grande la brave la courageuse la reine
du trot au zoo l'idole de vincennes
s'envole vers une nouvelle victoire une
victoire qui si elle rapporte peu aux
parieurs du tiercé couvre d'or l'heureux
gagnant d'un autre hymne national
vous savez on vit toujours avec l'espoir
de retrouver une jolie note fait je ne
pense pas qu'on entend une aussi par an
comment se fait-il que la jument à près
de huit ans face encore des progrès
alors sa joie je pense que c'est dû à
son état général elle a un coeur qui est
tout neuf aujourd'hui je suis content de
recevoir sur le plateau de tf1 actualité
celui qui est notre invité ses bellino 2
j'espère que ce cheval va se tenir
tranquille comme d'habitude c'est sur
les grèves du mont-saint-michel que
idéal du gazeau et son driver fidèles
eugène lefebvre ont préparé leur
victoire derrière les grilles de sa
prison dorée ourasi vient de se
réveiller le regard lointain il bâille
d'ennui être une star depuis si
longtemps ce n'est plus une équipe 13e
victoire consécutive pour jacques de
bellouet et de quelle manière il aura
mené de bout en bout sous les yeux de
son propriétaire
un cheval
un athlète
champion ready cash qui lance les
hostilités paris des caches s'envole
vers le toit du monde l'amérique on a le
nouveau ben saad
bonsoir bonne soirée
[Musique]
et ludivine lopez nous a rejoints pour
parler de votre carrière pierre aide des
reportages des chroniques des émissions
hippiques vous étiez une figure
incontournable des courses hippiques à
la télévision comment fait-on pour se
retrouver comme ça sur le petit écran
que faisiez-vous eh bien d'abord j'en
avais très envie de m'occuper de chevaux
de voir des chevaux etc et j'étais
shampouineuse dans le plus grand salon
de coiffure pour hommes est là parmi mes
clients il y avait des propriétaires de
chevaux de course et tout ça et un jour
j'ai vu l'un de mes clients disons
qu'ils visaient paris turf et je me suis
dit super il ya des shows et tout et je
me suis lancée j'ai eu le culot de lui
dire à vous avez de la chance vous avez
des chevaux mon rêve serait de monter
c'est chaud là
et c'était roberte forget il me dit pas
de problème j'appelle mon entraîneur
vous y allez quand vous voulez moi j'ai
tout de suite pris ma licence pour
monter en course d'amateurs un pas deux
pas avec les jockeys voulait pas de
femmes les jockeys et un jour il ya
andré la case qui était le rédacteur en
chef de paris match qui m'attend à la
sortie du vestiaire il me dit vous allez
me faire un petit pavé d'un quart de
page toutes les semaines sur les chevaux
vous avez monté ce qui courent le tiercé
il ya quinze jours après j'avais une
demi page et un mois après j'avais une
page entière dans son journal parce
qu'il trouvait que c'était génial et
qu'il y avait beaucoup de courrier qui
est tombée pour avoir des informations
hippiques sur le tiercé du dimanche donc
ça a commencé comme ça et personne
n'avait faire dans mois et après
effectivement grâce à lui vous vous êtes
retrouvé sur le petit écran ça on l'a
dit eh oui et vous imaginez bien que
grâce aux archives de l'ina on a
beaucoup de choses vous concernant on a
fouillé avec les documentalistes pour
trouver votre première apparition à la
télévision et c'est dans cette archive
qu'on vous découvre pour la première
fois elle date du 20 mai 1983 participer
au mal et la jument tonga le coup je
crois que c'est 63 63 oui exactement ce
soit sur 3 c'est pas que je mentais
réellement un peu trop vite exactement
vous participiez à un galop improvisé au
côté d'yves saint martin le célèbre eux
et le thème du reportage c'était les
femmes jockeys aux commentaires léon
zitrone un commentaire d'époque
dira-t-on
départ tout à fait acceptable et les
dames sur leur cursan mène grand train
peut être pour se changer du train train
quotidien
pour plus de sûreté le juge qui n'a pas
la télévision comme vous faites affiches
et photographies ces dames ne proteste
pas on n'a jamais vu une femme refusé de
se faire photographier en tout cas c'est
jeune femme aux traits tirés fatigué par
une compétition difficile vont se
transformer au vestiaire et un court
instant ans et charmante personne que
nous admirons tant dans la vie civile
alors ces cavalières ces charmantes
personnes comme les appelaient à lise
léon zitrone lé terrain dans les années
60 dans le milieu hippique d'ailleurs
c'est assez étonnant de voir un
reportage exclusivement consacré à l ce
que vous y étiez pour quelque chose en
participant là à cette émission bah
c'est moi qui les fais ce reportage
simplement léon zitrone ne pourrait pas
supporter que quelqu'un d'autre que lui
parle des shows de course donc il s'est
imposé moi je m'en souviendrai toujours
j'étais dans la salle de montage en
train de monter ce sujet il arrive
derrière moi et me dit non mais vous ne
créez pas de commentaire c'est moi qui
l'ait commenter ce sujet
c'était la pratique il m'a piqué mon
reportage pour aller faire mettre son
commentaire dessus j'étais folle de rage
parce que c'était rare de voir des
femmes comme à la télé les femmes des
femmes jockeys et aujourd'hui est ce que
les choses ont changé quelle est la
place des femmes dans le milieu hippique
il y en a partout
j'ai été l'une des premières mais j'ai
fais quoi là je vous garantis que alors
ça vient des femmes ou des filles
d'entraîneurs qui elle-même bas
vous travaillez avec le mari ou papa
voilà et puis après ben elles prennent
goût à l'histoire elle s'installe elle
même est actuellement il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes dans ce métier de
pyrèthre comment était perçue votre
présence dans le journalisme hippiques à
l'époque il y avait trois messieurs qui
s'appelait des bennes bernardez itron
qui était disons les rois mages du
tiercé et moi je me suis introduit alors
ils ont fait un peu la gueule bien sûr
parce qu'ils ont compris que il n'avait
pas ce comme le potentiel pour moi
j'avais de monter à cheval avec des
jockeys prenez sans les choux et tout ça
alors vous avez donné une nouvelle
dimension aussi aux au tiercé aux paris
hippiques à la télévision un oui les
pronostics de pire et brest sont
rapidement devenues un rendez vous
télévisuel très suivie c'est vrai aux
pronostics étaient suivis par des
millions de téléspectateurs en
1984 l'émission aujourd'hui la vie
s'intéressait aux phénomènes pierrette
brès vous étirer l'invité principal est
justement une journaliste interrogeait
des turfiste sur vos pronostics il avait
déjà joué d'après ses pronostics fiables
est arrivé vous avez gagné une fois vous
la trouvez d'où est
sorti on s'appuyer sur le recul elle
sort la culture est sérieuse ou en tout
cas et vous avez déjà suivi ses
pronostics spécialement non pourquoi
joueurs mangue et eshetu pas sur
l'adversaire ah non
bernard
lui parce que c'est un ami ça vous
dérange pas du tout pas du tout façon
dont le service est alors un nombre non
mais préfère les voir pour parler de
oba on en prend nom laisse un mois les
pronostics je me dis pas non plus loin
ses bottes professionnel je crois qu'ils
se débrouillent très bien qu'il ya
beaucoup d' introduction regarder auprès
des entraîneurs et tout le reste on sait
que ces pronostics sont beaux moyens
moyens ya moi je crois que c'est maya
c'est à dire que
elle s'y connaît très bien mes
pronostics c'est autre chose a je crois
que c'est
c'est pas pareil que sur une course vous
avez
vous avez entendu les avis étaient
mitigés est ce que je voulais vous poser
cette question pierrette est ce qu elle
était lourde à porter cette
responsabilité des pronostics moi
j'étais pas venu dans ce milieu là pour
faire des pronostics j'étais venu pour
parler du choix des choses voilà bon là
je suis obligé de faire des pronostics
je les fais mais je les faisais avec le
papier c'est à dire je savais que les
gars vous que je sélectionnés ils
avaient derrière eux un passé
intéressant maintenant vous savez un
cheval il a le droit de se sentir mal la
veille de la course
c'est un c'est un animal est pas savoir
ce qu'il va faire est ce que votre passé
de cavalière votre connaissance du monde
hippique vous ont aidé à asseoir votre
légitimité complètement complètement
parce que je vous dis les journalistes
hippiques de l'époque ne monte pas un
cheval c'était des turfiste il
s'intéressait aux choux aux pronostics
parce que il mettait de l'argent dessus
moi j'ai jamais joué aux courses
d'ailleurs parmi vos collègues certains
ne tarissait pas d'éloges à votre à
votre sujet et même parmi vos
concurrents regardez seyfried yates ah
oui madoré lui
monsieur theron oui
est ce que tu me permets de vous
demander ce que vous pensez de pierrette
bref au la réponse est très simple
excellente camarades oui phase est pas
assez long pour une interview peut-être
laissé c'est votre concurrentes quand
même non absolument pas non non c'est
avant tout une amie on se connaît depuis
depuis un certain temps elle exerce sur
une chaîne moi j'exerce sur l'autre
alors je préfère la formule jumelées que
concurrentes c'est ma rivale attention
pour les pronostics qui nous avons un
match terrible héritage c'est vrai il y
avait pas de concurrence entre
journalistes hippiques non enfin moi
j'ai jamais vu de concurrence parce que
les autres me faisait pas peur
voilà des noms perdre et ils étaient sur
une autre chaîne comme il le dit mais on
était très amis c'était un amour il
était d'une gentillesse incroyable
alors faut quand même préciser lille
ville que pierrette brès ça n'était pas
que des pronostics oui car au delà de
vos pronostics 1-2 bresse c'est un monde
que vous faisiez découvrir aux
téléspectateurs celui du milieu hippique
on cesse de le dire depuis le début de
l'émission dans votre émission diffusée
sur antenne 2 cheval de troie vous avez
interviewé de nombreux jockeys célèbres
tels que freddy head alain le cul ou
yves saint martin il faut dire qu'ils
arrêtent bref vous leur faisais faire un
peu ce que vous vouliez en 1983 par
exemple entre deux courses à deauville
les jeter à l'eau l'occasion pour vous
de faire vos pronostics
au fond de la piscine avec vous ils se
livraient sera quoi raconter leur
quotidien parfois dans leur plus simple
appareil on le voit ici il était très à
l'aise avec vous les jockeys mais je
faisais partie de la famille si j'avais
été une journaliste qui ne montrent pas
le matin à cheval avec eux et tout ça
est mort est ignorée mais au début ils
m'ont bizuté d'ailleurs j'ai eu droit à
tous les bijoux tâche pas si mal quand
ils ont compris que j'étais quelqu'un
qui s'intéressait vraiment à leur métier
que je faisais la même chose que je
montais des galops j'allais faire les
boks le matin je préparais mon choix
lavande voilà moi ils m'ont acceptée
dans la grande famille mais il fallait
faire ses preuves car vous parlez de
cette famille c'est aussi un réseau qui
vous a ouvert des portes absolument
incroyable vous avez côtoyé des
personnalités alors des personnalités
politiques sportives également qu' qui
apprécient les chevaux qui sont même
propriétaire ludivine oui des
propriétaires donc on l'a dire vous les
avez rencontrées vous les avez côtoyé
aujourd'hui parmi les propriétaires
célèbres y lire françois bayrou je ne
sais pas si vous le saviez très bien
antoine griezmann sont aussi il est
aussi exactement deux jeunes
propriétaires et justement le
footballeur en parlait dans l'émission
tout le sport en 2019 sur françois on
écoute et une autre passion les chevaux
et les courses et ouais j'ai commencé il
ya un an et demi je crois
voilà j'adore j'adore aller les voir à
l'écurie
je le vis mal pendant les courses mais
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de stress mais
mais c'est vraiment quelque chose que
j'adore pirette ses propriétaires connus
est ce qu'ils font ça par passion et
bien avouer que c'est un investissement
ah non non non c'est un investissement
oui mais sont pas forcément perdante
dans cet investissement
et c'est la passion qui les anime oui
vous sur votre carrière pierrette brès
en plus donc de la découverte du milieu
hippique on l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est
aussi votre passion pour le milieu
équestre que vous partagiez dans vos
reportages vous pariez des chevaux bien
sûr vous alliez aussi à la rencontre des
métiers équestre maréchal ferrant
dentiste pour équidés la cause animale
faisait aussi partie convient aux
préoccupations certains de beaux
reportages étaient même diffusé dans le
jt comme celui ci en 1980 sur antenne 2
vous dénonciez l'horreur des conditions
de transport ac aurait les chevaux
destinés à l'abattoir vous l'avez dit on
les images sont difficiles à jamais
au cours de ces transports les chevaux
sont trop souvent victimes de la
stupidité ou la méchanceté des hommes
dans par exemple pour un voyage de sept
mille kilomètres on entasse pendant dix
à vingt jours une douzaine de chevaux
dans un wagon en mélangeant mâles et
femelles le drame est inévitable deux
étalons en présence d'une jument se
battre sauvagement rêveur et si on lui
passe un noeud coulant au lieu d'un
l'école le cheval pris de panique se
débattra jusqu'à la mort ce cheval bai
brun ou second plan refusé de sortir du
wagon pour le punir nos mieux couper la
langue il est mort d'une hémorragie
cet autre cheval est devenu aveugle à la
suite de coups
alors là ce n'est
la journaliste qui parlait c'était la
militante pierrette brès avant l214 oui
et je suis très fier de ça parce que
j'ai fait changer beaucoup de choses
j'ai fait changer beaucoup de loi dans
certains pays par exemple en grèce où il
y avait un gros marché de chevaux pour
l'abattoir ils mangent pas de cheval les
grecs ils hésitent à néant mangent les
choux été achetés par les italiens et
pour aller en italie est là pour qu'ils
aient le droit de partir comme chevaux
de boucherie il fallait qu'on leur crève
les yeux ou qu'on leur un casse les
jambes c'est ça me paraissait ahurissant
pourquoi donc moi j'ai plus le sujet à
coeur et quand je suis arrivé à paris
j'ai dénoncé tout ça est l'ambassadeur
de grèce à paris m'a appelé il m'a dit
venez me voir il faut qu'on se parle
vous rendez compte à deux mois des du
tourisme vous nous casser tout notre
marché il faut faire un démenti ou
plaisanté moi je fais un démenti sur
quelque chose qui est vrai j maintenant
vous vous pouvez faire quelque chose
venus est quoi cette loi à la con là où
on ne doit manger les chevaux que l'on
ce qu'ils ont fait la guerre et qui sont
blessés de guerre vous allez la faire
enlever cette loi et les shows ne seront
plus martyrisé comme vous le faites il
l'a fait mais non mais je suis une
militante pour la défense des shows bien
évidemment et aujourd'hui se prêtent
encore à me battre s'il le faut
pierrette vous avez quitté france
télévisions depuis déjà quelques années
quel regard vous portez aujourd'hui sur
les courses hippiques les suivez vous
allez venir dans dix jours ici au au
prix d'amérique pour les grandes courses
je me souviens pour le reste moi j'ai
une faculté extraordinaire c'est qu'une
fois que j'ai tourné la page je reviens
pas en arrière je suis contente d'être à
vincennes je suis contente d'y aller
pour les grands prix d'
à longchamp et partout ailleurs de m
chapeau à voilette le machin vu tout ça
j'aime bien
merci en tout cas à vous d'avoir répondu
notre à notre invitation merci à vous
ludivine alors traditionnellement dans
l'inattendu on se quitte avec une petite
pépite pierrette on finit en chansons de
temps en temps c'est le cas aujourd'hui
entre vos émissions si vous avez poussé
la chansonnette à la télé c'était en
1992 vous en souvenez vous la chance aux
chansons avec pascal sevran ou souvenez
de ce que vous avez interprété ce jour
là
oui c'était
chanson d'aznavour oui oui la moyenne la
bohème eh bien regardez j'étais morte de
c'est comme si on y était non owen
la bohème
ça voulait dire
on est heureux
à l'om
la bohème
nous ne mangions qu'un jour sur deux
dans les cafés voisins nous étions
quelques-uns qui attendions la gloire
et bien que miséreux
avec le ventre creux nous ne cessions
d'y croire et quand quelques bistrots
contre un bon repas chaud nous prenait
une douane
nous hésitions des groupés autour du
poêle en oubliant l'hiver
vous en sortez superbe cadeau non merci
beaucoup pire et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine c'est toujours sur le
canal 27 france info et toute la semaine
bien sûr sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit ce dina et ceux de france info
émission préparée avec notre
documentaliste emilie galtier laurence
made you lie merci à elle et merci à
vous d'être là chaque semaine
[Musique]